[Music]
mastering
any physical skill be it performing a
pirouette
playing an instrument or throwing a
baseball takes
practice is the repetition of an action
with the goal of improvement and it
helps us perform with more ease
speed and confidence so what does
practice
do in our brains to make us better at
things
our brains have two kinds of neural
tissue gray matter
and white matter the gray matter
processes information in the brain
directing signals and sensory stimuli to
nerve cells
while white matter is mostly made up of
fatty tissue
and nerve fibers in order for our bodies
to move
information needs to travel from the
brain's gray matter
down the spinal cord through a chain of
nerve fibers called
axons to our muscles so how does
practice or repetition
affect the inner workings of our brains
the axons that exist in the white matter
are wrapped with a fatty substance
called myelin
and it's this myelin covering or sheath
that seems to change with practice
myelin is similar to insulation on
electrical cables
it prevents energy loss from electrical
signals that the brain uses
moving them more efficiently along
neural pathways
some recent studies in mice suggest that
the repetition of a physical motion
increases the layers of myelin sheath
that insulates the axons
and the more layers the greater the
insulation around the axon chains
forming a sort of super highway for
information connecting your brain to
your muscles
so while many athletes and performers
attribute their successes to muscle
memory
muscles themselves don't really have
memory rather
it may be the myelination of neural
pathways that give these athletes and
performers their edge
with faster and more efficient neural
pathways
[Music]
there are many theories that attempt to
quantify the number of hours
days and even years of practice that it
takes to master a skill
while we don't yet have a magic number
we do know that mastery isn't simply
about the amount of hours of practice
it's also the quality and effectiveness
of that practice
effective practice is consistent
intensely focused
and targets content or weaknesses that
lie
at the edge of one's current abilities
so if effective practice is the key how
can we get the most out of our practice
time
try these tips focus on the task at hand
minimize potential distractions by
turning off the computer or tv
and putting your cell phone on airplane
mode in one
study researchers observed 260 students
studying
on average those students were able to
stay on task
for only six minutes at a time laptops
smartphones and particularly facebook
were the root of most distractions
start out slowly or in slow motion
coordination is
built with repetitions whether correct
or incorrect
if you gradually increase the speed of
the quality repetitions
you have a better chance of doing them
correctly next
frequent repetitions with allotted
breaks are common practice habits of
elite performers
studies have shown that many top
athletes musicians and dancers
spend 50 to 60 hours per week on
activities related to their craft
many divide their time used for
effective practice into multiple daily
practice sessions
of limited duration and finally practice
in your brain
in vivid detail it's a bit surprising
but a number of studies suggest that
once a physical motion has been
established
it can be reinforced just by imagining
it
in one study 144 basketball players
were divided into two groups group a
physically practiced one-handed free
throws while group b
only mentally practiced them when they
were tested at the end of the two-week
experiment
the intermediate and experienced players
in both groups
had improved by nearly the same amount
as scientists get closer to unraveling
the secrets of our brains
our understanding of effective practice
will only improve
in the meantime effective practice is
the best way we have of
pushing our individual limits achieving
new heights
and maximizing our potential
[Music]
you